THIS MORNING THE URGENT SEARCH
FOR A KILLER OR KILLERS.
AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY ON EDGE IN
NEW MEXICO.
FOUR MEN, ALL MUSLIM, SHOT AND
KILLED SINCE NOVEMBER, THREE IN
THE PAST TWO WEEKS.
A MOSQUE SPOKESMAN TELLS CNN ONE
OF THE MEN ATTENDED A FUNERAL
FOR TWO OF THE OTHER VICTIMS ON
FRIDAY AND THEN BECAME A VICTIM
HIMSELF JUST HOURS LATER.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA IS IN
ALBUQUERQUE THIS MORNING WITH
THE LATEST.
THIS HAS TO BE TERRIFYING FOR
THAT COMMUNITY, ED.
>> Reporter: THERE IS NO
QUESTION, JOHN, THESE MURDERS
HAVE SENT A CHILLING REACTION
THROUGHOUT THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY
HERE IN ALBUQUERQUE, NEW MEXICO.
WE'RE TOLD IT'S ABOUT 3,000 TO
4,000 MUSLIMS THAT LIVE HERE IN
THE ALBUQUERQUE AREA.
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF CONCERN
EMERGING BECAUSE THERE IS SO
LITTLE INFORMATION AS TO WHAT IS
GOING ON.
THE FIRST MURDER HAPPENED BACK
IN NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR, SO
ABOUT TEN MONTHS AGO.
THAT IS WHEN THE FIRST PERSON
WAS KILLED.
THEN NOW IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS
WE HAVE SEEN A STRING OF THREE
OTHER MURDERS.
ONE ON JULY 26, ANOTHER ONE ON
AUGUST 1st AND THEN, AS YOU
MENTIONED, THE LATEST VICTIM WAS
A MAN WHO HAD ATTENDED THE
FUNERAL SERVICES OF THE TWO
PREVIOUS VICTIMS.
FRIDAY AFTERNOON HE WAS IN THE
MOSQUE BEHIND ME, TALKING TO
PEOPLE, ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT WAS GOING ON, CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON, AND
THEN A FEW HOURS LATER HE WAS
KILLED AS WELL.
WHAT ONE THINK THAT ALBUQUERQUE
POLICE BELIEVE IS THEY ARE NOW
CONNECTED AT THIS POINT.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE CASE.
THE ONE THING TYING ALL THE MEN
TOGETHER IS THAT THEY ARE
MUSLIM, THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO
HAVE BEEN ANY ROBBERY OR ANY
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE CRIME THAT
WENT DOWN THAT WOULD SUGGEST
THAT IT WAS SOMETHING OTHER THAN
THE MEN BEING MUSLIM AND BECAUSE
OF THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
MOSQUE HERE WAS TELLING US LAST
NIGHT THAT THERE IS A GREAT DEAL
OF FEAR RUNNING THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY HERE IN ALBUQUERQUE.
>> ED, WHAT ARE MUSLIM
LEADERS --
>> PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED.
>> INCREDIBLY TERRIFIED,
PANICKED, SOME PEOPLE WANT TO
MOVE FROM THE STATE UNTIL THIS
THING IS OVER, SOME PEOPLE HAVE
MOVED FROM THE STATE, BUSINESSES
ARE CLOSING, THEY'RE CLOSING
BUSINESSES EARLY, STUDENTS DON'T
LEAVE THEIR HOMES, PEOPLE ARE
NOT -- IT'S AFFECTING PEOPLE
FROM COMING OVER TO THE MOSQUE
TO CONDUCT THEIR SERVICES, THEIR
PRAYERS.
SO IN EVERY ASPECT OF DAILY LIFE
THAT WE ARE USED TO OR
ACCUSTOMED TO FOLLOWING, IT'S
BEEN -- IT'S IMPACTED IT IN
EVERY WAY POSSIBLE, BUT I GET IN
THE CAR AND I'M WATCHING EVERY
WHICH WAY POSSIBLE, I'M WATCHING
MY SIDE MIRROR, I'M LOOKING IN
THE BACK, I'M LOOKING OUT FOR
ANY SIGN THAT -- OF ANYTHING OUT
OF THE ORDINARY.
>> IT'S HARD TO LIVE LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, I MEAN, AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT IS -- WE DON'T HAVE
AN ALTERNATIVE.
>> Reporter: AND, JOHN,
YESTERDAY AFTERNOON ALBUQUERQUE
POLICE RELEASED THE PICTURE OF A
GRAY WHAT THEY BELIEVE TO BE A
VOLKSWAGEN JET TA OR PASSAT,
THEY SAY IT IS A WEEK OF
INTEREST CONNECTED TO THE AREAS
THAT SOME OF THE PEOPLE WERE
KILLED.
THEY BELIEVE THAT THAT COULD
LEAD THEM TO SOME IMPORTANT
CLUES IN FIGURING OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE.
>> WE'RE PUTTING THE PICTURE UP
SO PEOPLE CAN SEE IT.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU HAVE ANY
INFORMATION LET THE AUTHORITIES
KNOW IN ALBUQUERQUE.
WHAT ARE MUSLIM LEADERS TELLING
PEOPLE?
WHAT ARE THEY ADVISING THE
COMMUNITY TO DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES?
>> Reporter: YOU CAN IMAGINE THE
FEAR THAT THIS HAS INSTILLED IN
SO MANY PEOPLE.
POLICE SAY A LOT OF THESE
VICTIMS WERE ESSENTIALLY
AMBUSHED, SURPRISED AS THEY WERE
GOING ABOUT THEIR LIVES DOING
MUNDANE THINGS, ONE MAN HAD
WALKED OUT OF THE BACK OF THE
GROCERY STORE HE RAN, WAS TAKING
A BREAK WHEN HE WAS SHOT AND
KILLED, ANOTHER PERSON WAS
WALKING ALONG THE SIDEWALK.
MUSLIM LEADERS TELLING PEOPLE TO
TRAVEL AROUND THE CITY, USE A
BUDDY SYSTEM TO KEEP TABS ON
EACH OTHER, TO NOT STAY OUT AT
NIGHT IF THEY DON'T HAVE TO.
REALLY JUST KEEPING TABS ON EACH
OTHER, DO NOT TRAVEL ALONE AND
ALWAYS BE AWARE OF THEIR
SURROUNDINGS BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE SO MANY OF THESE VICTIMS
HAD SIMPLY JUST BEEN SURPRISED
AND AMBUSHED.
>> ED, THANK YOU FOR BEING THERE
FOR US, PLEASE KEEP US POSTED.
JOINING US NOW IS THE MAYOR OF
ALBUQUERQUE, TIM KELLER.
MR. MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
WE JUST PUT THE PICTURE UP OF
THIS VEHICLE OF INTEREST.
ANY OTHER LEADS YOU CAN TELL US
ABOUT THIS MORNING?
>> WELL, RIGHT NOW THIS IS THE
BEST LEAD THE PUBLIC CAN HELP US
WITH.
SO, WE KNOW THIS VEHICLE HAS
BEEN CONNECTED TO THE SCENES FOR
A COUPLE OF THESE INCIDENTS.
WE'RE ASKING EVERYONE,
ESPECIALLY IN OUR COMMUNITY DOWN
HERE, TO HELP US TRACK THIS
DOWN.
IT'S A RELATIVELY UNIQUE
VEHICLE.
WE KNOW THERE'S ROUGHLY 100 OF
THESE IN CENTRAL NEW MEXICO.
SO, IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF TIME
AND IDENTIFICATION OF FINDING
THIS VEHICLE.
OF COURSE, CONNECTING THE DOTS
FURTHER TO BRING JUSTICE TO
WHAT'S HAPPENED.
THIS IS OUR BEST BET RIGHT NOW.
>> OBVIOUSLY, ALL FOUR VICTIMS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE, MUSLIM
MEN.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU CAN TELL US
ABOUT HOW THESE CASES ARE
LINKED?
>> AT THIS POINT IN THE
INVESTIGATION WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE AND FOCUS ON THAT AS OUR
PRIORITY.
SOME OF THAT REALLY MEANS NOT
SHARING EVERY DETAIL OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT
THESE ARE OBVIOUSLY TIED
TOGETHER, THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY
TARGETING MUSLIM MEN AND
HAPPENING RIGHT HERE IN OUR OWN
REFUGEE COMMUNITY, HISTORICALLY
WHICH HAS BEEN A VERY SAFE AND
WELCOMING AND INCLUSIVE PLACE
FOR DECADES.
AND SO OUR COMMUNITY IS
EXTREMELY IN A PLACE OF GRIEVING
RIGHT NOW, BUT ALSO IN A PLACE
OF OUTRAGE THAT THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN OUR CITY.
>> NOW, OFFICIALS AT THIS POINT
TELL US THEY AREN'T USING THE
WORD HATE CRIME TO DESCRIBE
THIS.
WHY?
>> WELL, IT WAS CERTAINLY A
HATEFUL ACT.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO CALL IT WHAT
IT IS.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY TARGETING MUSLIM
MEN, A STRING OF KILLINGS ALL
RELATED.
WE KNOW THAT.
NOW, THERE ARE DIFFERENT TERMS
THAT SPEAK TO MOTIVE AND I THINK
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE NO
INDICATION AS TO MOTIVE.
WE DON'T EVEN HAVE AN INDICATION
AS TO WHERE THE PERPETRATOR IS
EVEN FROM.
THE ASSUMPTION IS THEY'RE FROM
HERE.
THEY MIGHT NOT BE.
IT IS THE NORM IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES THAT YOU
DON'T CATEGORIZE THINGS WITHOUT
KNOWING THE MOTIVE.
CLEARLY IT'S HATE-DRIVEN.
>> SO, NO EXACT INFORMATION ON
MOTIVE YET, OTHER THAN THE
IDENTITY OF ALL THE VICTIMS.
ANOTHER PHRASE THAT AUTHORITIES
HAVE BEEN LOATHED TO USE SO FAR
IS SERIAL KILLER.
WHY?
>> WELL, IT'S A SIMILAR
SITUATION THERE IN THAT, AGAIN,
WE HAVE A STRING OF KILLINGS AND
THEY'RE TARGETED TOWARDS MUSLIM
MEN.
WE KNOW THAT THAT IS THE CASE.
AND THAT'S WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
FEEL THAT THAT TERM REFLECTS.
BUT IF YOU WORK WITH THE FBI AND
SO FORTH, AGAIN, THAT TERM
SPEAKS TO MOTIVE.
AND, AGAIN, WE -- UNFORTUNATELY,
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT RIGHT
NOW.
THERE COULD BE A NUMBER OF
MOTIVES THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE
SPECIFIC TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
FOR DIFFERENT TYPES OF REASONS.
>> MR. MAYOR, YOU KNOW, YOU WERE
SPEAKING ABOUT THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY AND THE FEAR THAT MUST
BE GOING THROUGH THAT COMMUNITY
AND YOUR CITY RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU WERE A MUSLIM MAN, HOW
COULD YOU FEEL SAFE GOING OUT IN
PUBLIC?
>> WELL, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW FOLKS IN OUR COMMUNITY,
THE MUSLIM COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY,
THEY ARE AFRAID TO EVEN LEAVE
THEIR HOUSE, ESPECIALLY AT
NIGHT.
THEY'RE AFRAID TO PRAY, THEY ARE
AFRAID TO START SCHOOL.
THAT'S WHY OUR CITY, WE HAVE
MARSHALLED EVERY RESOURCE TO
HAVE NOW POLICE PRESENCE AT ALL
OUR MOSQUES DURING PRAYER TIME.
WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR DIFFERENT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS WITH RESPECT
TO SAFETY AT SCHOOLS AND
SPECIFIC SORT OF BUDDY SYSTEM
RELATED PROGRAMS AT SCHOOL FOR
KIDS.
WE'RE EVEN DEAL MEAL DELIVERIES
FOR FAMILIES THAT ARE AFRAID TO
LEAVE THEIR HOUSE, EVEN TO GET
FOOD.
WE'RE ALSO PROVIDING COUNSELING
AND TRAUMA.
WE ARE MARSHALLING EVERY
RESOURCE WE CAN TO BOTH MAKE THE
COMMUNITY FEEL SAFE AND ALSO TRY
AND UNDERSTAND, WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT THIS COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE
PHYSICALLY SHOW UP FOR THEM.
>> I WAS GOING TO ASK, WHAT'S
YOUR MESSAGE TO THE MUSLIM
COMMUNITY IN ALBUQUERQUE THIS
MORNING?
>> THEY KNOW THIS IS NOT OUR
CITY.
WE HAVE HAD A LONG-STANDING,
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
MUSLIM COMMUNITY THAT GOES BACK
HUNDREDS OF YEARS.
WE BELIEVE WE ARE ABSOLUTELY
UNIFIED FROM THE HIGHEST LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT DOWN TO OUR
NEIGHBORS AND OUR COMMUNITY ON
THE STREET IN PROTECTING AND IN
SUPPORTING THIS COMMUNITY RIGHT
NOW.
AND WE ARE GOING TO GET THROUGH
THIS AND WE'RE UNIFIED IN THAT
EFFORT.